here is iPhone 10 now unlocking it is as
easy as looking at it and swiping up and
you know let's try that again
oh-ho-ho let's uh go to back up here now
let's go to back up but minor
malfunction this week while Apple
executives we're showing off the new
iPhone 10 a facial recognition feature
called face ID did not work as planned
glad to see it happens to other people
face ideas the iPhones newest security
feature it uses a 3d scan of the users
face to unlock the phone and while its
cutting edge technology it's also
raising questions about privacy and
security Andy Greenberg has been
covering these concerns for Wired where
he's a senior writer and he is here with
us today Andy good morning good morning
so we've heard about other facial
recognition technology where you can use
a photo to trick it but with the iPhone
that's not the case right it's not going
to be that easy to spoof your face as it
has been for like the Galaxy s8 or other
facial recognition systems where you
could just show it a photograph the the
new iPhone this the iphone ten is going
to use tens of thousands of infrared
dots on your face that it projects
itself and it uses an infrared camera to
see how those are distorted and to get a
kind of 3d map of your face this is not
going to be easy to spoof but I have
that malfunction yet despite all this
you need to have had glitches but then
I've talked to hackers who say they're
going to break this and in fact if you
remember the the touch ID fingerprint
reader on the last iPhones yeah those
were broken within days of the release
of the phone just in demonstrations but
that is that doesn't mean that like you
know a malicious hacker couldn't do this
and your face is out there on Facebook
and Instagram they can if they can
assemble those public facial photographs
of you into a model then they can break
into your phone right so you mentioned
the fingerprint ID that they've had on
the phone for a few years here now
why are they doing away with that
because that was hackable well Apple
seems to have this like war on an
inconvenience where even even just like
that having to have a little one button
on your phone is too many so they want
the experience to be so seamless that
you don't even notice the features or
notices
so this the idea is that you'll just
look at your phone that it'll recognize
you you don't even have to show it your
finger so okay we should be clear that
this is a compromise of the security of
your phone for convenience and in fact
the the safest thing you can do is to
turn off your fingerprint reader your
face print reader and just use that six
digit PIN code which is remarkably
difficult to break in an iPhone it's
interesting because I think I always
thought that the fingerprint technology
would you think that yeah and it's not
the Bible like biometrics are not
necessarily the safest way better well
there's a few reasons why not I mean
first of all the sixth is a digit
passcode is just mathematically almost
impossible to guess given the number of
tries that Apple yeah
offered to you and we saw that with the
the Apple versus FBI conflict last year
yeah the FBI couldn't break into a phone
with a six digit passcode without apples
help until they you know probably got
the help of the NSA or someone then
there's this issue of the fact that you
can be very easily coerced to show your
finger or more easily your face to
someone who wants to break into your
phone whether that's you know a mugger
or a kidnapper or the police if they
have a warrants you can actually refuse
to give your passcode and believe the
Fifth Amendment's in many cases against
self-incrimination you can't refuse to
show them your face I mean it's right
there so it's gonna be many ways easier
to break into phones with biometrics
than with a pin which I mean even the
ACLU calls facial recognition one of the
most more dangerous by biometrics I
think that Apple is doing it in the
safest way that you can do it yeah but
they're also by virtue of releasing this
thing that's gonna be a millions of
people's hands it's gonna train
Americans to use their face as a
security mechanism and once we're used
to that it's just a matter of time and
so you know tech companies are uploading
those faces and Apple is not but maybe
you know Amazon or Google or somebody
else will create a database of face
printers right or you know maybe it'd be
useful how well you know that just might
be the way that they more kind of easily
let you log into your you know your
online accounts with your face and if
they keep that centralized database or
for a government agency does then it's
only a matter of time until their leaks
and then we're really in trouble in
terms of privacy and security
so many are going towards that biometric
standard there Andy Greenberg thank you
we appreciate it thank you guys